pergunta: "Como conseguir o protocolo
sobre doença autoimune? Assistir o seu
vídeo no YouTube. Oi, pessoal, recebi
essa pergunta sobre protocolos para
doenças autoimunes e sei que muitos de
vocês estão nessa busca. Então, vamos
conversar sobre as principais abordagens
da medicina funcional, especialmente o
famoso protocolo autoimune, a IP, né, da
sigla autoimmune Protocol.
Primeiro vamos entender o que acontece
numa doença autoimune. É como se o
sistema de defesa do corpo ficasse
confuso e começasse a atacar o próprio
time. Pode ser tirodite rashimoto,
artrite amatoide, lupus, psorize. A
lista é grande, são mais de 80 tipos
diferentes. E sabe qual que é o
denominador comum? Inflamação e
permeabilidade intestinal aumentada. O
protocolo IP é uma estratégia alimentar
de estilo de vida dividida em três
fases. Na primeira fase, a eliminação.
Você retira temporariamente os alimentos
mais inflamatórios. E olha, a lista é
grande. Glúten, laticínios, ovos, grãos,
leguminosas, açúcares, óleos refinados,
os night shades que é o tomate, pimentão
e beringela, nozes, sementes. Meu Deus,
doutor, que que sobra? Calma que eu
explico. O que você pode comer? Carnes
de qualidade, peixes, muitos vegetais,
excesso à classe dos night shades,
frutas com moderação, raízes com batata
doce, mandioca, gorduras boas como
azeite e óleo de coco, ervas,
especiarias naturais. É comida de
verdade, sabe? Nada processado. Essa
fase de eliminação dura entre 30 a 90
dias. é o tempo do seu intestino se
recuperar, a inflamação diminuir e os
resultados podem ser impressionantes. Um
estudo mostrou que 73% dos pacientes com
doenças inflamatórias intestinais
entraram em remissão clínica em apenas
seis semanas. Alguns até conseguiram
parar a medicação. Depois vem a fase
reintrodução. Você vai adicionando um
alimento por vez aos poucos observando
as reações. É tipo um trabalho detetive.
Às vezes você descobre que pode comer
ovos numa boa, mas tomate te inflama,
então cada corpo é único. Agora sobre a
dieta carnívora, sobre a qual eu fiz um
vídeo há aproximadamente três ou 4 anos,
existem muitos relatos anedóticos de
grande sucesso para doenças autoimunes,
mas infelizmente ainda tem evidência
científica pequena, não é robusta.
Existem riscos consideráveis se não for
feito com muito cuidado, porque a
maioria das pessoas não gostam de comer
víceras onde se encontram vitaminas que
não estão presentes no músculo da carne.
Então, temos riscos de deficiências
nutricionais, alterações no microbioma,
falta de fibras. Portanto, não recomendo
como primeira opção, mas pode ser uma
ótima opção, se bem orientado por um
nutricionista ou médico que entenda de
nutrição. A dieta mediterrânea, por
outro lado, tem bastante evidência
científica, rica em vegetais, azeites,
peixes, nozes, tem ação antiinflamatória
comprovada e é mais fácil de seguir a
longo prazo. E os suplementos, vitamina
D é fundamental. A maioria dos pacientes
autoimunes têm deficiência dessa
vitamina também. BH3, zinco, selênium,
especialmente para tireoide,
probióticos, glutamina para recuperar o
intestino, mas tem que ser
individualizado. O mais importante, isso
aqui não é modinha, é mudança de estilo
de vida. Tem que incluir sono de
qualidade, manejo do estresse, exercício
regular. O protocolo AIP não é só sobre
o que você tira do prato, é sobre o que
você adiciona na sua vida. Mas doutor
parece muito difícil, eu sei. No começo
é desafiador mesmo, mas quando você
começa a assistir melhor, tem mais
energia, menos dor, menos sintomas, aí
você entende que comida é remédio e o
melhor sem efeitos colaterais. Se você
quer começar, procure um bom
nutricionista e um bom médico da
medicina funcional. Não é só copiar
lista da internet, precisa personalizar,
fazer exames, acompanhar, mas eu
recomendo sim que você estude. Você vai
achar muito material gratuito através de
uma busca no Google ou com a ajuda da
inteligência artificial, mas sempre
cheque pelo menos três fontes
diferentes. Uma boa forma de fazer isso
é com aplicativo Perplexity, que junta a
busca na internet com avaliação de IA,
mas tome cuidado, pois mesmo assim às
vezes IA alucina. Então, portanto,
sempre cheque os resultados. Cada pessoa
é única, cada doença autoimune tem as
suas particularidades. Mas uma coisa eu
garanto, vale a pena tentar. Já vi
tantas histórias de transformação que eu
me emociono toda vez. Yeah.